[Music]
what i love about this trip is that it's
an opportunity
to explore places that i haven't had a
chance to explore before
we are setting out from toronto but
we're taking the slow road
up through muskoka cross through
algonquin park through the ottawa valley
and eventually down to montreal
[Music]
the muskoka region lends itself to
cranberry growing because of the acidic
soil
it's a miracle fruit exactly
i know what you're thinking how do i get
me one of these
i grew up in toronto i've seen leaves
and i've appreciated the color
but this is something altogether
different this is a sea of color
and you can't capture it in any other
way except to stand there and see it for
yourself
you have to make a stop at henrietta's
pine bakery it's like
the thing to do 57 years i think they've
been
serving up these muskoka clouds
[Music]
it's really really good one of the
reasons that people come to algonquin
park for the fall colors is the fact
that it's so accessible there's just
nothing like it anywhere else
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
kanataki means the land without frontier
wapi my horse and gretel
your horse and we're in general our
company
it's to reconnect people with the nature
animals so this is their new bus
okay you know what makes this part of
the world
unique is that you quickly feel a part
of something
it was brighter and bolder than i
thought it would be there were far more
adventures to be had than i
expected incredible culture fantastic
food
beautiful landscapes it's all right here
let's see what time you live all right
[Music]
you